relocations from san francisco to texas
florida jumped between 32 to 46
and 2020 fox business the kobe 19
pandemic accelerated migration from the
us in 2020 compared to 2019 but
particularly
from large urban areas like san
francisco and new york to
sun belt metro cities like austin dallas
charlotte according to a study published
by the cbre real estate group
a summary of the study notes that many
of those who left these cities may
return once the pandemic is over
about 135 000 more people left
california in 2020 that moved in making
the third largest migration laws
in states history several large
california companies including oracle
hull packard and enterprise move their
headquarters to texas
these are big companies by the way yes
to move your headquarters
to texas in 2020 and tesla's elon musk
moved to houston
in december tech executive including
palantir
chairman peter thiel and former paypal
executive
keith rabo recently moved to miami as
the city's mayor francis suarez attempts
to court the big tech players to south
florida suarez nicknamed
miami the capital of crypto and capital
of capital
in two separate tuesday tweets we were
at the event we were on the other side
when he said those things yes ricky your
thoughts uh
it makes sense i mean it makes sense for
them why would you want to stay in san
francisco
uh where they literally have a map uh a
crap
map right where they have a map to where
people take the most traps in the city
and you so you could walk around it san
francisco yeah did you know that
kai go to san francisco crap map oh did
you bring us the map
it's a ship map it's you know it's a
suffragette we're looking up right now
crap map
san francisco images of crap in san
francisco
look at the first one yeah it's a so so
that's not true go to the second one
that shows you right there right and
where there were they were
where the you know homeless are taking
unbelievable so they have a crap map
hoop maps yeah this is ridiculous it's a
poop map like that
you didn't know they had a pet i had no
idea yeah i had that's where you can go
no no that's what they're doing they're
handing out needles
for the drug addicts so they don't pass
hiv to each other whatever the case may
be
so but how far is this from silicon
valley uh
how many miles an hour an hour
give or take yeah i have a team up there
so it's not it's about an hour
give it about about an hour hour and a
half maybe at the most depending on
traffic
so uh going back to going back what
you're saying is you're not surprised
no 100 percent well forget about what
does it say 32 miles
san francisco silicon valley
so traffic is about an hour but so so to
answer your question though pata uh
it doesn't surprise me first of all
because of the condition san francisco
used to be a beautiful it's still a
beautiful city beautiful sights
but when you live there you're dealing
with these things it's different to go
there for the day and go with your
family to live there
right that's number one and then on top
of that number two is when you're
dealing with uh
you know uh they they did a 15 hour at
an hour minimum uh if you run a business
you can't afford to pay people that plus
workers complex that plus have a profit
right so yeah it only makes sense that
people are living
leaving san francisco as a matter of
fact in bakersfield where i live in
bakersfield california
we had a big migration of people from
san jose san francisco
uh vallejo uh salinas moved on a
bakersfield because that was well the
housing
rate was a lot cheaper and uh and it was
affordable to live so now i'm not
surprised they're moving to texas 100
makes sense if you live in california
you'd understand why they're moving by
the way give you a crazy statistic here
i was doing a video yesterday about you
know uh uh
moving to florida okay why i chose to
move to florida et cetera and the video
actually gives you
reasons why i chose to move to florida
it's coming up probably what next
tuesday to come out right
one of the stats that's absolutely
staggering is the following how many
total homeless people you think we have
in america
total in all of america
yeah give me an over under how many
total homeless people we got say we got
first let me give you total u.s
population as of right now i think it's
330.
i'm going to say 350. okay u.s
population
uh is at 3 328. in 2019 it was 3 28.
let's say it's 3 30.
okay at 3 30. how many homeless people
you think we have in america
i would say uh i'm gonna go with a
million patent
okay what do you say it is
two million okay so both of you are off
according to the
u.s department of housing and urban uh
development which is the hud 580 000
homeless people in america which by the
way
you figured there's probably more but
that's the number that they haven't
registered right let's just say 580 000
people that are
homeless you know how many of that 580s
from california
160. give or take 160 one-fourth of it
one-fourth a little more than one-fourth
of all the homeless people
in america or from california or from
the state of california
do you know during the pandemic just in
the city of l.a
not california homelessness increased 20
000 people in the state in the city of
l.a 20 000 people in the city of
homelessness so are you surprised that
people are leaving california to move to
texas or florida are you
i mean how confident was suarez at the
dinner the other night
how confident was he got a shout out to
francis suarez mayor miami the guy's
swaggy to begin with
i saw his picture oh my god the guy's a
supermodel he looks like a superman
we took a picture with him yeah i've
interviewed him before
is it just a solid dude but when you're
when you're the mayor of miami you're
already in a strong position to begin
with you're the freaking mayor of miami
but now during the pandemic
everything that's been going on do you
know how much confidence and swag you
can develop
right now you could play offense you can
recruit you could say listen what the
hell are you doing in california
right he took a shot at cal uh new york
no problem saying look
they're they're already a mess and
they're trending in the wrong direction
come on down to florida i mean his
famous tweet was
to the big texas how can i help you yeah
how can i help yeah
and he is helping he like he said he
wants miami to be the capital of capital
so maybe
let me ask the question different ways
what is your name pat i'm sorry what is
it what way does it lean
uh center right center right got it
center right as a mayor it's not really
too much
somewhere says democrats some words says
conservative but i would put him as a
center
right guy okay i would put him as a
conservative
socially yeah that's the best way to put
it but but here's a question for you
here's a question for you here's a
question for you
say pandemic is over with pandemic is
over with everything's back to normal
everybody got their vaccines except
ricky and a couple other people right
let's just say the vaccines got
everybody being comfortable right except
for small community
that's not going to get the vaccine shot
honestly 50 of republican men
unless if they force the passport id
there's going to be some people getting
arrested because some guys are just not
going to do it
that's just going to be you're not going
to be able to get everybody to get the
vaccine but okay
let's just say most people get the
vaccine fine
what percentage of people are going to
move back to california
that's the question the moment somebody
moves out what percentage is going back
and saying okay things are
clear that's the settle i'm moving back
to new york
i'm moving back to california what
percentage will go back so
the the most important question on
things like this is how much of this is
permanent yeah
how much it is temporary damage control
what do you think
i mean look this is all just sort of
speculation but i think if you're moving
you're making a decision to move your
family if you especially if you have
kids if you have a family and kids and
you move
you're gone if you're a single guy you
know how many single people
i know that have moved out of new york
into miami literally every single friend
i know
where are you from where you from from
where you live where you live i was from
new york i'm just down here for a year
it's a lot easier to you know if you
have flexibility if you're single keep
it moving obviously you know i've been
yeah
over the last 10 years if you've got
family you've got kids you've got to
roll them in school and you're maybe
buying a house like you're gone
that's it a lot of people from
california move to
nevada or they move to arizona they move
to tennessee some people obviously to
florida
i would say the the vast majority let's
say eighty percent
are gone maybe twenty percent eighty
percent are gone
yeah if you're families with kids you're
aggressive no no i agree with you i
actually agree with you
i think that we got a first ding ding
ding can i get up i know huh
i think that uh what ends up happening
is that like for example i travel a lot
so i get to see a lot when you don't
leave california you don't realize
how with the laws and all this how bad
it is until you go to another state
you're like you can do that you're like
yeah it's yeah we can
how much you pay in taxes oh wow you
start
opening your eyes to a different world
so i think that once you open your eyes
to a different world
you realize that schooling is better you
realize that your second amendment is
not being infringed on
you realize that you know the government
is just kind of leaving you alone do
your thing build your business and we're
going to leave you alone
you're going to you know you go to red
states and it impresses you you're like
i could live like this in america you
don't really in america california you
don't realize how much of a chokehold
you have until you leave california
you don't realize that you can't do this
you can't do that you can't do this you
can't do that we can do this we can
can't do this can't do that until you go
to another state where you they're like
we don't really care what you're doing
just don't kill anybody we're good
just don't kill it well i think
obviously the pandemic exacerbated
all of this because now it's acceptable
to wfa wfh work from home work from
anywhere it's completely acceptable
so if i asked you a year ago two years
ago ricky what are the chances that
you're moving to mississippi you'd be
like
bro no zero no now if you can work from
anywhere
and you can own guns and and work from
anywhere and
be left alone and low taxes you might
consider living in a state that at a
million years you would have not
considered
not to call out our mississippi and
friends you know what's hurting some of
these states
here's what's hurting some of these
states so for example say twitter says
moving forward nobody ever has to come
into the office right right
i'll say i want to work for twitter okay
great work for twitter
but i want to work for twitter living in
texas living in nevada living in
nashville living in tennessee living in
calif living in
florida but i want to work for twitter
twitter says no problem you're hired
you're a coder
so i live in florida but i work for
twitter
but i don't pay the taxes of the state
it doesn't matter who's paying me i'm
paying the state taxes where i live
which is what florida
so a lot of these companies in silicon
valley in new york
who went out there and started saying
what oh we're hiring people
virtually you don't have to be here they
actually hurt the state
they're actually having to say that
they're based of course because you pay
taxes based on where you live you don't
pay taxes
based on where the company lives yes in
some cases they've also said i know
at least early on they said oh you'll
have a you won't have a silicon valley
rate if you if you don't live there
so they're paying proportionately
depending on where you live sure
they are yeah in that sense it's saving
them money to get
yeah but watch this but what does that
do think about what that does
again who does that hurt whether they go
lower
or whether they go out of state you know
who else that even hurts even more
people living in america because i can
now hire people if i'm going 100
zoom why the hell am i paying u.s rates
why wouldn't i twitter go higher
engineers have at india
out of philippines out of armenia these
places are producing some of the best
engineers
why am i even paying full price here i'm
not going to be full price
so a big part of new york in california
what they did
they indirectly change the business
model on how even silicon valley and
these financial companies are working
this is not as you know small of a thing
as people think
the consequences of certain things you
do sometimes the side effects takes a
decade
right to experience it right i think
this is going to be a side effect that's
going to take five to 10 years for us to
really see what happened
you're going to sit there and say what
the hell for example you go to glendale
where armenians at they live in glendale
where are syrians that they're in
turlock
where are uh you know venezuelans at you
know maybe orlando miami
a lot of them were orlando miami where a
lot of cubans that okay you'll say miami
we're puerto rican where dominicans at
where i was at where italians at new
york why
because once one community moves to a
place they typically tend to stay there
unless if you treat them what you know
you treat them bad and then they leave
right so
they have to know this could be a shift
taking place right now
and some of it is not done by
politicians believe it or not
some of it is done by these corporations
by these corporations who are leaning
far to being hey you know you can work
from home do whatever you want to do
they're hurting the state just as much
as the policies in the state are hurting
the state
right but do these corporations actually
care about the state they care about
their company
wow but here's the thing there used to
be time where you would be like hey you
know you know i want to have my
headquarters in new york
why because new york has the best what
talent
pool right you know i don't want to live
over here why because
now guess what the title is everywhere
the talent coolest everywhere right so
you can no longer say
i'm in new york because the talent pool
is in new york nope that's not the case
anymore
isn't that like the best thing for
capitalism though there's no research
it's a fantastic thing for capitalism
it's a beautiful thing for seven states
but it hurts states like new york
california and illinois well new york
can either adjust
or fall by the way so they're not going
to judge they just impose another four
point three billion dollars
to make obviously and by the way they
just impose another 4.3 billion dollars
of taxes by cuomo
and they have to impose it there's
nothing they can do about it
the state's going to go bankrupt if they
don't get that 4.3 billion dollars
so cuomo's people are sitting there
saying if you don't raise this four
point three billion dollars guess what
how the hell are we gonna get we need
this money here so
he's in a pickle himself he's not
allowed i'm surprised i haven't recalled
yet
cuomo him yeah you know a lot of a lot
of uh efforts being made a lot of people
in california just waiting
uh to see what's gonna happen with
newsome before they leave like i know we
i know a lot of people have their finger
on the trigger they're just like okay if
we don't recall him we're out
because he has two more years on his
term uh but i know a lot of people
they're like
you know they're just waiting they're
just waiting to see what's gonna happen
with this recall
and if he gets recalled her out so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]